This 16-year-old sophomore was born with a brain disorder.
And bullies have always been a part of life.
Until this year, when her mom called on a family friend for help.
It was Carson.
Starting quarterback Carson.
I e-mailed Carson and told him Chy was having some issues.
I just wanted names...
...and he took it a step further and went and gathered Chy at lunch.
And she's been eating with them ever since.
From first hour through the end of the day,...
...Chy's guys make it a point to look after her.
And this group's newfound friendship has changed the game.
They're modest about their small act,...
...but to Chy, high school is a new world,...
...a safe one.
You say, "My team, these are my boys," right?
Yeah.
And why is that?
Because they saved me.
Because I won't get hurt again.
All because a group of boys broke those silly social rules.
And through it, earned a loyal friend.